[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 le journal
voici les titres à neuf jours du second
débat de la primaire de droite bruno le
maire et est en meeting hier soir à
saint germain en laye l'occasion pour
lui de présenter son programme
une opération de prévention routière
s'est déroulée hier à la verrière
organisé par des policiers et des
pompiers le but est de sensibiliser les
citoyens aux risques de la route
et puis on finira ce journal avec les
vacances de tous la toussaint qui sont
un peu particulière cette année elles
ont débuté mercredi dernier
les communes ont dû s'organiser pour
accueillir les enfants
neuvième jour de mouvement de
protestation des policiers se sont
rassemblés aujourd'hui devant tous les
palais de justice de france et notamment
celui de versailles et où ils étaient
une quarantaine
ils réclament entre autres la révision
des règles de légitime défense
notre journaliste nicolas kirillovitch
interviewé match à ce gaillard
secrétaire départemental du syndicat
unsa
le rassemblement d'aujourd'hui c'est
pour que il une conscience qu'ils soient
prises au niveau du pouvoir judiciaire
nous demandons une application plus
ferme des des lois et des peines qui
qu'encourent les individus qui seraient
auteurs de violences à l'encontre des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique comme les policiers quand des
peines sont prononcés à l'encontre
d'auteurs de violences contre les
policiers
nous estimons que les peines sont trop
faibles pour que ce soit significatif et
empêcher les récidives il faut que ce
soit des peines qu'ils puissent être
dissuasive grève aujourd'hui des
travailleurs sans papiers à sodexo à
guyancourt la cgt à l'origine de la
grève réclament au groupe des récépissés
avec autorisation de travail pour tous
notre journaliste camille lambert était
sur place
ils étaient une centaine ce midi à
manifester pour leurs droits
ces travailleurs sans papiers sont venus
réclamer la régularisation de leur
situation
groupe sodexo située à guyancourt des
salariés pour beaucoup licencié par
l'entreprise pour défaut de papiers
selon la cgt
aujourd'hui il risque l'expulsion tout
travail doit être reconnue et notamment
pour les sans-papiers ben ça veut dire
que l'employeur assume ses
responsabilités et donne les documents
nécessaires
on a déjà déposé plus de 250 dossiers en
préfecture qui sont en cours de
traitement donc ça devient urgent
d'avoir les documents pour compléter le
dossier
la cgt affirme avoir voulu entamer les
discussions avec le groupe il y a
plusieurs mois mais sans retour
les manifestants souhaitent récupérer
les attestations permettant de
reconnaître leur travail et de rester
sur le territoire c'est le cas d'ibrahim
arrivé en france il ya six ans
toute ma vie en france je vais rester en
france comme un collègue dos ils ont
travaillé ici ils ont participé au
développement de ce pays aujourd'hui
s'ils sont intégrés de manière normale
donc je vois pas pourquoi
non il nous faut mieux comprendre le
sujet il nous faut donc écouter les gens
on a une tradition dans le groupe qui
est l' écoute de nos collaborateurs on
va l'appliquer
donc ce que nous allons faire on s'est
entendu avec avec les représentants des
collaborateurs pour pouvoir recevoir
des gens qui sont désignés par le groupe
les travailleurs continueront leur
mouvement tant qu'ils n'obtiendront pas
satisfaction
actuellement le dialogue se poursuit
entre les deux parties en france et
selon les estimations entre 200 et 400
mille personnes vivraient en situation
irrégulière politique toujours à neuf
jours du second débat de la primaire de
la droite les sept candidats continuent
à sillonner la france
bruno le maire était hier soir à saint
germain en laye il a développé son
programme devant une dizaine de
sympathisants
notre journaliste nicolas qui révèle
vite étaient sur place sur des images
d'une première nous allons arriver au
sommet quelles que soient les
difficultés parce que les français
veulent le renouvellement de la vie
politique de faire preuve de renouveau
bruno le maire veut garder le cap et
répète son message à l'envi depuis des
semaines un slogan est une marque de
fabrique également scandé hier par
l'ancien ministre de l'agriculture en
meeting à saint germain en laye et qui
semble ravir ses futurs électeurs à la
primaire
c'est déjà ce qui me pousse à aller vers
bruno le maire puisque j'exclus voter
pour quelqu'un qui a un casier
judiciaire vierge
j'exclus de voter pour les sortants
puisqu'ils ont un bilan
le fait de porter une certaine éthique
pour moi c'est très important
un certain dynamisme une jeunesse et
l'envi de nouveaux éducation sécurité ou
encore économie le candidat à la
primaire a développé une partie de son
programme devant plusieurs dizaines de
ses partisans lui qui reste optimiste
malgré des sondages qui le placent loin
derrière encore les ténors du parti
beaucoup de gens me disent voilà on va
très bien pour vous mais on veut avoir
l'assurance que le nicolas sarkozy soit
battu donc on va voter pour alain juppé
je connais pas une bonne motivation pour
son vote
on doit voter pour un projet et pour une
personne qui porte ce projet pas contre
un homme ou contre une personne
ce deuxième déplacement dans les
yvelines en l'espace de quelques mois a
permis également au député de l'eure de
mesurer ses soutiens dans le département
on a aujourd'hui environ 1200 militants
sur le département ce qu'il fait une
force de mobilisation importante et on a
aujourd'hui à peu près 120 130 élus
locaux qui nous ont rejoint un certain
nombre de maires laurent bros philippe
benassaya bernard grouchko plusieurs
conseillers départementaux et régionaux
et donc on a une vraie force politique
et populaire qui permet de porter notre
candidat prochain grand oral pour bruno
le maire jeudi 3 novembre date du
deuxième débat de la primaire à cause du
triste bilan sur les routes yvelinoise
36 morts et 800 blessés depuis le début
des plus début janvier des actions pour
sensibiliser aux comportements à risques
se multiplient dans le département
c'était le cas hier à la verrière où des
ateliers étaient proposés
reportage mélanie poquet et patrick
jacques de dixmude
cette menace est là qu'elle fait à
droite droite et la gauche
ces enfants vers hyérois seront les
conducteurs de demain s'ils ne sont pas
encore au volant la sécurité routière ça
prend déjà commencé à éduquer les
enfants jeunes ce comme une langue
étrangère plus vous l'apprenez jeunes
plus bas cette langue elle va elle va
vous rentrez dans le var entraînant dans
dans le cerveau et puis vous allez après
ce sera un automatisme ce qu'on occulte
qu'aujourd'hui aux enfants c'est la
sécurité la sécurité routière et il en
parle aussi à leurs parents et voyais
les défauts leurs parents et aujourd'hui
c'est très très productif savoir manier
son vélo comprendre la signalisation ou
encore se rendre compte de l'impact de
l'alcool sur la perception
les plus jeunes ont pu découvrir les
comportements à adopter pour les freins
balle monsieur tout à l'heure il m'avait
dit faux faut pas freiner avec tes pieds
moi j'avais l'habitude de freiner avec
les piéger afrique dès qu'elle s'en
allait tourner en rond point et après
j'y suis allée sur l'ordinateur pour
faire mieux plus des enfants
j'ai appris qu'il fallait rester sans
trottoir à des mamans ou si fanny soir
sur la route en effet pressé échelle
cette journée était assurée par les
agents de la sécurité routière de la
préfecture et de la police municipale
des ateliers ludiques pour faire baisser
les chiffres de la mortalité routière
trente six personnes ont perdu la vie
sur les routes du département depuis le
début de l'année et c'est une première
dans le domaine
waze est la ville de versailles ont
signé un accord de partenariat
grâce à cet accord toute les données
liées à la circulation seront
directement retransmise en temps réel
grâce à la participation de la ville
le partenariat devrait s'étendre aux 19
communes de l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc
les championnats d'europe de cyclisme
sur piste ont fermé leurs portes ce
dimanche tous les âges les sportifs
européens étaient sur place et les
journalistes du monde entier sont venus
couvrir l'événement faisons un point sur
cet événement qui a duré cinq 5 jours
avec un reportage d'un michael et demi
d'euros
28 nations 270 coureurs les championnats
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste sont été
pendant cinq jours la capitale
européenne de la discipline le public du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines a pu voir en action la grande
bretagne l'italie la belgique ou encore
l'allemagne
je pense que c'est vraiment très bien
d'être ici et j'aime bien la piste
c'est vraiment très sympa c'est un gros
événement pour regarder vers le futur
incroyable c'est aussi très bien d'être
encore en français oui j'aime bien la
langue
j'aime bien aussi la france en général
comme ça c'est trop bien d'être ici des
nations moins réputés sur le plan du
cyclisme ont également fait le
déplacement c'est le cas de la lituanie
le pays situé sur la rive orientale de
la mer baltique a envoyé une équipe de
cinq coureurs et a notamment remporté le
titre sur la vitesse individuelle une
compétition très longue
je suis dans l'équipe de sprint j'ai le
keirin et aujourd'hui j'ai le sprint
c'est un prénom rica et qu'on range sur
le plan médiatique plus de 50
journalistes du monde entier ont couvert
l'événement
nous fournissons un tas d'informations
sur notre site internet
comme les résultats des photos des
petites histoires sur la compétition
pour te dire à former les gens tout ce
monde se retrouvera l'année prochaine à
berlin pour l'édition 2010 est des
championnats d'europe cette année les
vacances de la toussaint sont un peu
particulières avons débuté mercredi
dernier les parts ont dû organiser mais
les communes aussi de l'agglomération
comme la ville d'elancourt par exemple
faisons le point avec notre journaliste
nicolas bordry un vacances particulière
planning particulier le centre de
loisirs jean monnet à la clé st pierre
s'est préparé spécifiquement en congés
de la toussaint en cause le début des
vacances en milieu de semaine avec des
conséquences forcément sur
l'organisation
on a attendu déjà de pouvoir accéder à
nos listings pour
combien d'enfants d'aller accueillir on
a vu tout de suite qu'il allait y avoir
une grosse différence entre le jeudi et
vendredi du début des vacances où on
accueillait jusqu'à 92 enfants et
aujourd'hui par exemple lundi 24 octobre
on a plus que soixante deux enfants donc
on a un tiers des enfants qui ne sont
plus présents qui sont partis en
vacances c'est un peu plus que ce qu'on
a l'habitude d'accueillir en général sur
les plates de vacances de la toussaint
en tout cas ces dernières années
pour ces vacances deux animateurs
supplémentaires ont été embauchées pour
le jeudi et vendredi
même constat dans les autres centres de
loisirs d'elancourt les familles
généralement s'organise sur ses vacances
à savoir qu'il ya toujours une semaine
qui est dédiée aux grands parents et
l'autre semaine qui en centre de loisirs
donc ils ont une façon de s'organiser
qui est plutôt bien rodée l'a cette fois
ci ça a déstabilisé un peu tout le monde
parce que les grands parents sur le jour
c'est un peu plus compliqué et puis pour
la mairie ça l'a été aussi
face à une recrudescence d'enfants sur
les jeudis vendredis c'est à dire + 22 +
25 % d'enfants la mairie d'elancourt a
dû mettre en place plus d'animateurs
c'est dans la gestion du personnel que
cela a posé des difficultés ce à un coût
financier puisqu'il faut déployer sept à
huit animateurs supplémentaires sur le
reste de la semaine une soixantaine
d'enfants sont attendus au centre de
loisirs jean monnet et une quarantaine
pour le lundi 31 octobre et le mercredi
2 novembre avant le retour à l'école
prévue le jeudi 3 novembre et les
chiffres du chômage viennent de tomber
et -2 2% en un mois pour le département
l'évolution globale n'est plus que de
0,7 pour cent dans les yvelines
plus d'infos dans notre prochaine
édition demain c'est la fin de ce
journal je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis
[Musique]